[Music]
[Music]
okay yeah
let's should we go should we finish up
on the new main [ __ ] should we watch
his other the other yeah quickly just
kind of like
[ __ ] on new main we can just quickly
[ __ ] on new mane
i mean that kid [ __ ] sucks man he's
just the epitome
of everything we've talked about how
like the concept of
like he represents that [ __ ] where it's
like originality
like do you remember when dudes on vine
would do this and it was like
constant harassment you know like dudes
on vine would steal [ __ ] and it was like
you [ __ ] thief delete this now and
the biggest creators could be shamed
into deleting something yeah
they had to start putting inspired by
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it like copying and stealing
used to be a big deal but that's that's
that's what i'm
i mean like what was even more worrying
than this is how all the comments
on people on the post calling him out i
mean like some of them
are like i can't believe you guys are
crying over some stolen tick tocks y'all
are crying over some tick tocks and it's
like
dude tick tock is just totally
uh ingrained in the next generation that
like this is fine and it's
kind of fine you're stealing ideas it's
like
yep i mean and i yeah i don't know
there's a difference between
also there's a different difference
between being inspired by something and
coming up with your own version of it
yeah and this what this kid's doing
which is directly stealing look at this
play this one let it rip
[Music]
frame for frames
how can you even say that's acting when
you're not even doing your own [ __ ]
you're just
mimicking what someone else is doing
that's not acting yeah
i i can't believe what it is what planet
is this acting
no mars maybe yeah no he's acting he's
acting like the person who made it
yeah yeah okay so he's fulfilling the
role as being the person who made it
yeah yeah you just wouldn't get it man
i'm not off the jeter enough to
understand
that no you don't get it dude you're not
like a real actor
doctor it's acting you're not a [ __ ]
actor dude i'm foxed and waxed and ready
to ask
when i come outside it's like i'm ready
to do my thing
duh you know
that's why that's why my name is newman
because i'm new man because i i g
on every set i'm a new man
that was sick oh suck
those sock stocks no problem
slotted
there's no real smart commentary there
he just stinks and he
he is that that that new gen that new
thought which is like oh whatever there
wasn't that you could never go i can't
believe you're mad about some vines
no one would ever say that i mean it's
just like it's like the entire
integrity of creating content and making
people laugh
and having your own ideas how do you
feel good about a creator when you're
not coming up with your own [ __ ] i know
how do you feel good about yourself
when you're literally frame for frame
stealing someone else's things maybe if
you added another
a different caption or a different word
maybe you could sleep at night because
you'd be like i added a little bit
something to this even though it's still
kind of [ __ ] up but
he's not doing that it's frame for
[ __ ] frame
it's like you're literally just a clone
do you know what we should do
um we should we should do like an art
project where we hire someone to carbon
copy either
uh or like john oliver we'll literally
just have him
redo all of john oliver's [ __ ] bits
yeah and then we'll go i can't believe
you guys are [ __ ] crying over some
reporting oh my god
or like music yeah people have done that
though but
you know if we just created like um
mavis scott yeah and we just we just
redo literally all his music the guy's
voice is totally different
kimberly is just crying over some
[ __ ] music man dude it's just
music man y'all are crying over some
stolen music it's [ __ ] stupid bro
yeah whatever dude it's just [ __ ]
sicko mode
original's not even that good headlining
a massive festival
boo you stole this music can we guys are
crying over some [ __ ] music i just
make your [ __ ]
better yeah yeah that's why your shit's
not popping dude i'm not a writer i'm
not an
act i'm a director sorry i'm not an
actor either actor
i'm a musician i'm performer dude that's
what i do i perform
i'm gonna [ __ ] write the music i'll
perform it
and i'll make your [ __ ] good let's go
live right now and see how many people i
can piss off with some stolen music
stolen music people can cry about it
it's like you he's got millions of
followers
he's probably making money off other
people's [ __ ] yeah
stealing money from someone pretty much
yeah
well dude it's like it's like i've
always said you know stand up you stole
a joke you're [ __ ] ass beat
yeah that's all
there's just no element of that with
tick-tock there's really no consequence
for stealing [ __ ]
yeah kind of dumb i know you see him do
you ever notice like tick tocks that
like you've seen before
and someone does like just tweak the
premise slightly
it's like make it theirs yeah but you
could like just sniff out like something
just feels inauthentic about it yeah
it's just it blows my mind like new
man's not the only guy to do it
like a lot of kids do it super weird
but whatever that's bizarre man i mean
it's definitely possible to have like
similar
thoughts so stuff like that's hard to
take or
hard to criticize but this yeah easy
like it's literally just
shot for shot which is annoying but
whatever
douche yeah what a douche
all right what we're going to talk about
hey new main
kind of douchey [ __ ] you're doing over
there still calling out for building his
account almost completely from stolen
videos including one of mine and not
long after i posted it newman messaged
me on instagram trying to get me to
delete it and it was clear that he was
trying to scare me into doing it he had
this tone of light if you delete the
video i'll forget this ever happened
but if you don't you'll have more
enemies i'm not kidding that's exactly
what he said
[Music]
the video for about a day but not
because i was scared i just
didn't want to become the drama tick
tocker you know there's always so much
fighting and arguing with all this app
every day i didn't want to add fuel to
the fire then i realized
me posting that video wasn't me starting
drama i was just standing up for myself
so i unprivated the video and not long
after
newmaid sent me another message saying
that he's gonna sue me for false
accusations i think he's lying like what
is a judge going to do about a tick tock
it just really feels like he's been
trying to bully me
into staying silent and that's not going
to happen the video's stinging
the video bro [ __ ] judge goes i can't
believe you're trying
to it goes to new man i can't believe
you're [ __ ] crying over some tick
tocks
not guilty the [ __ ] out of my courtroom
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
what are you about to say i'm just gonna
say i love when
like i love when dudes like that try to
seem like more powerful than they are
like he was like
my team you'll be hearing from my team
well we're gonna
sue you dog you don't have a lawyer and
if you do it's your [ __ ] dad
[Laughter]
you don't have a team you're a [ __ ]
tick talker
you know what i'm saying like my team is
gonna reach out what do you have a
[ __ ] manager at a social media agency
bro
a team in my opinion implies at least
like five
yeah yeah exactly like that's afraid
like that's just a phrase people have
like
taken from people who actually have
teams yeah what i'm saying yeah
like the dude at chase is like you're
gonna [ __ ] hear from my team it's
like oh yeah there's like
17 people yeah who are going to come
after me yeah
i love it this guy's got a point of
contact yeah that's what he has
that's his team is a point of contact at
an mcn or something
that sends him uh weekly updates you
know like a uh like a duet
deal every two months duet this make 200
bucks
that's his that's his team
yeah dude my team over there at [ __ ]
um
collab yeah yeah my team over at collab
is gonna come [ __ ] take you out
for [ __ ] what for false accusations yeah
get out of here man are you threatening
legal action man
play this one
[Music]
[Music]
it's a little it's a little roast like
that i like that i like that i like that
now i like the kid who green screened
himself in front of new mains
video and he was like uh i'm acting
and he just like was like blocking
humane but doing exactly what he was
doing
acting baby yeah that's some [ __ ] like
acting
watch us be completely wrong though
watch him get cast
as the next halftime show at the next
jake paul fight you know and
he goes on stage and does that for the
whole time yeah
and he gets paid six hundred thousand
dollars given how everything's going
he will be in the next new chris nolan
movie yeah yeah he'll be in the highest
grossing film exactly 2022 and he will
be one of the most sought after
actors in hollywood and he's going to
blackball us from
everything because we talk [ __ ] that's
how it's going to go yeah he's actually
going to be new maine is actually going
to be um
uh he's going to be like action heroes
in the 90s he'll be in literally
every long format title they're going to
they're going to recast um [ __ ]
uh what is it goddamn what's that hbo
show
um enthusiasm no massively popular uh
game of thrones
no it's about like the high school kids
euphoria yeah they're gonna recast
euphoria
but new maine as the lead yeah yeah and
the best part is
is his only obligation in those shows
will be to do
that to go yeah the directors go
crazy for that [ __ ] they know new maine
all you gotta do okay so wait so uh you
know zendaya
zendaya is going to be over here and
she's got this really intense scene
where she's
emotionally distraught about something
but she's torn apart
about this other thing and so there's
going to be a lot of conflicting
emotions in this scene
and then new main you walk in you just
go yeah
and we're gonna play the music for you
and all you gotta do is you do your
thing man you know people
love to see what new maine do yeah and
we'll play the music for a year we'll
play
and we go once you do that little little
dance you do you know what i'm saying
and people are gonna go crazy man
here's the best part is we're gonna have
the camera on you the whole time so we
actually won't even see any of the other
talent we already spoke to your team and
we made sure that
they will not be on frame with you at
the same time you'll be the only person
on frame yeah
because that's what you deserve man yeah
and i know you did the same thing in
the six last movies that you did but we
talked to your team
and they said they're cool with it you
know as long as we pay you you know
enough
which we are we're paying you handsomely
trust me yeah
right do it i can't do it you do it
that's that's the laugh of
um we're good here right we're good here
right
here right here right right right
sorry must have some of snoop's weed
earlier hey
yeah i don't know i just i want to stop
talking about him because he stinks
okay let's move on [ __ ] coin what do you
got to say about it
you